[Music]
hello and welcome back to chess openings
explained as always my name is caleb
denby
and today we are going to be taking you
through part 982
of the nydorf today we're focusing on
the 13th side variation
no of course just kidding we're done
with the night or i hate that opening no
more
10 videos was enough today as the title
says we're going to be taking a look at
some pretty
awful horrible chess openings um
that were played by michael john uh
basement
bassman not entirely sure how to say his
name he is
an english chess international master
that was big
back in the 1980s even a little bit
before that
and uh he was well known for playing
some of the most uh horrible awful
garbage chess openings that i have ever
seen
uh and so i'm gonna be taking you
through some of these games we're gonna
see
how uh you know michael is flaunting
opening principles left and right and
why he's getting away with it why
isn't he losing these games outright
thought it'd be a nice little bit
of a fun break after the grueling series
on the night or if the theory heavy the
the serious stuff so we'll take a look
at it here
up first i have a game between frank
babar
against michael john basman of course
uh and frank i had to google his name
unfortunately was not familiar with him
and he's around 2100 feet a so we're
we're starting off a little bit
you know a little bit slowly here all
right but i promise you
this michael john basement guy he he can
beat you can beat the real chess players
but we're going to start off with this
game
because it was you know absolutely
insane and i thought i should
definitely highlight it so frank being a
chess player you know
bobby fischer fan says e4 best buy test
and you know i i'm pretty sure michael
just like looks
at the chess board starts thinking on
move one and
this game he came up with the move h6 so
h6 of course
not going to be the most advisable
opening
of all time of course it does not
control the center
it does not develop any pieces it does
not go towards getting the king to
safety
and makes very very little sense so why
is
michael playing this move h6 well we'll
see a little bit later on
if he reveals his hand and then frank
being a weirdo plays the move b3 and
it was at this point that uh you know i
could already tell we were gonna be in
for quite a game so what do we think
about this move
b3 why does white play b3 here well
maybe frank was a little bit familiar
with his opponent and
knew that michael had a very serious
tendency
to play the move g5 to follow up h6 and
this is sort of
the types of games michael was famous
for playing he would go for an early g5
he did play the grub quite often
with white as well he would go for some
kind of king side attack
so i think frank may have been prepping
for this move one h6 believe it or not
and now g5 of course is very heavily
discouraged
because this bishop is going to land on
b2
so at this point michael sort of
switches gears plays the move e6 instead
i see bishop b2 b6 g3
and now bishop b7 and bishop g2
so what do you guys think about how
white handled
uh michael's treatment of the opening
here
uh of course frank faces one h6
by black and then he immediately double
fianchettos
uh what do you think about this response
to michael's opening play we're going to
see a few different approaches tonight
uh in how to respond to the absolute
insanity
that michael has been playing throughout
his chess career and this i think is is
a little bit more conservative
so what do we how do we feel about this
manny says why b3 and g3 isn't this a
little weakening
and yeah a lot of people in the chat
here are hitting upon sort of the the
right idea
so in the opening we very much should
value our time
every move we play costs us you know one
unit of time a tempo
and so if whites can use those tempo
those 10 b rather make them very
valuable early early on
then black is going to feel very unhappy
about playing the move
h6 if white is able to open things up
activate his pieces right away
take over the center of the board black
may live to regret playing this little
h6 move however
when you play as frank has played here
with b3 g3
bishop b2 bishop g2 it's true that white
gets a very very solid position
but at the end of the day um he's not
going to be left with that much of an
advantage right
you know what did you do when black gave
you a free move with h6
uh well frank played b3 and developed
the bishop out to b2 not a bad piece by
any means
but it's not really going to refute
michael's opening here so knight f6
appears on the board
uh threatening this e4 pawn very
directly so we see d3 by frank
then believe it or not it's actually
michael who starts to take over the
center
with the move d5 so
now at this point uh frank could have
gone for some king's indian attack style
positions something like knight e2
uh to follow maybe knight d2 would be a
good start as well
but instead he decides to take over the
center with e5
and now knight fd7 by michael and
d4 is the follow-up by frank
and already i have to confess i'm
starting to like
black's position why do i like black's
position here well
frank's opening while you know
classically following the principles
i think is actually worse than michael
john baseman's here and that
is even after michael has played the
move 1 h6 and that's part of why i
wanted to highlight this game
and a lot of the games that we're gonna
see in the lecture here today
just because your opponent plays one or
two
awful horrible horrible looking moves
doesn't mean
they are going to get the worst position
of all time yes michael played h6
on move one yes it does not control the
center or develop any pieces
or help castle the king but after that
his play has been very logical
he piled up his pieces on e4 he provoked
the pawn
move to e5 and now he is going to target
the center with the move c5
look to activate this bishop a little
bit later on
and all of his pieces will be serving
useful purposes here
not only that but he still has some
options open to
even try to expand on the king's side a
little bit later on so even h6 may turn
out to be a useful move
in the meantime white has developed two
bishops
to fianchettos and they are both staring
at an entirely closed center and that is
that is how white has
spent his time here white now continues
with c3 further proving that this bishop
is a mistake knight c6 is natural
development knight e2
and now bishop a6 and suddenly even this
bishop that once looked pretty bad for
black
is active once again castles is played
and then we just see it captures on d4
captures on d4
and then h5 so now officially stating
that h6 was just a waste of a tempo but
what has black done well he's gotten
white to commit his king to the king
side
he's found nice solid pressure on the d4
pawn he's made his opponent's pieces
fairly bad out of the opening and he has
you know a pretty reasonable plan
so uh well of course classically we
would say
he played a horrible horrible opening
with h6
now when the dust is settling i'm not so
sure white
is thrilled with how this game has gone
white continued with the move
h4 going for f5 plans and just h4
by basement here you know he's not even
done developing
right this knight is very very loose on
c6 this bishop has not moved the king is
in the center
he doesn't care he's pushing on the
king's side he's gonna go mate the guy
g4 by frank keeps the h file closed and
helps prepare f5 but now
h3 takes even more space for michael
john baseman
bishop f3 and now queen out to h4
and a3 and yeah
like i keep saying here i think i would
even rather be black
in in this position white's pieces just
make absolutely no sense they are just
scattered
throughout the board and while black's
pieces aren't the most coordinated of
all time
i think they make more sense than uh
than whites here bishop on a nice open
diagonal
this bishop controlling some squares
even if it hasn't moved and the knight
pressuring the center a little bit
this knight admittedly doesn't make the
most sense but hey
you know what three out of four is not
bad
michael follows this up with g5 which i
will say is maybe a little bit too much
but it is definitely in the spirit of
how he's been playing the position
frank plays this move f5 we see
e takes on f5 bishop takes on d5
and now this pawn is hanging with check
i'm not entirely certain why it wasn't
captured
i would probably recommend capturing
this guy but ruxia instead
is just defending the knight and this is
what was played and then both players
absolutely lose their mind bishop takes
f7 appears on the board
rook takes f5 check king e8 knight g3
um and now knight e7 is the move
for white knight d2 and i would like you
guys to find
the only move for black that equalizes
here
can you find one of the only moves for
black
to equalize the game you could argue
that you know maybe a few moves are
playable
but i think this is the best move to
equalize and probably
the best move to uh to play for an
advantage here what do you guys think
try to get in the mindset of michael
john basement think
of how you've been playing this opening
you know what you want to do
wow and danilo has successfully
channeled his inner michael baseman of
course
of course we are pushing the h pawn down
the board
one step at a time are we gonna let a
puny little h-pawn
get in our way no no of course we are
not
you gotta take that knight get rid of
that h pawn and push h2
all right king h1 by frank and now
there's just one piece remaining
one piece standing in the path of uh
of this h pawn how are we going to get
rid of it well basement starts by taking
a free rook which makes sense we have g
takes f5
and now bishop b7 check and
suddenly you know white is running out
of squares on this diagonal and may very
very quickly
just be checkmated he finds a good move
here frank does with the move d5
uh and now of course if bishop takes d5
we would see knight f3
and this bishop has sort of been drawn
to an undefended square
uh so instead of that uh michael you
know just down a queen
is like yeah casually all right i'll
i'll attack the pawn again
with my rook and then here
you know chess is fun and all but
sometimes it's it's not this fun
white does in fact miss a win here
although there are only really two moves
that do it
the idea is to go queen f3 and the point
now
is that you can occupy the e4 square
with your knight rather than the f3
square
and now white is going to be able to
successfully sort of blockade on this di
on this long diagonal and should end up
surviving the day
but instead e6 is played and rook takes
d5 now
uh of course e takes d7 would be met by
rook takes d7
with check knight here loses to
checkmate so you would have to give the
queen back
and again black is actually going to be
better because
he has more rooks in this position this
rook can save itself
oh yeah by the way e6 attacks both of
these pieces it's
wild game rook takes d5 was played
knight c5
was the follow-up for michael john
basement again just bringing more pieces
and this time uh by the way okay so
white plays queen f3 first the idea
being if you're d2
then of course bishop queen b7 so
michael john baseman just defends this
bishop
bishop takes h8 is played now rook takes
d2 the queen comes off the board
and the dust has settled michael john
baseman is up at night
and goes on to win this game pretty
convincingly here the rooks get traded
and uh frank babar resigns
so that is the first michael john
baseman i wanted to show you guys
um this can't be a classical match i'm
pretty sure it was i'm pretty sure i
didn't do super deep research
this was the lloyd's bank masters open
but
uh yeah you know it's easy to say after
seeing that game right
okay both players were going a bit crazy
frank you know
very decent chess player i'm sure but
not exactly
you know world class uh he was around
2100 feet a
when i looked him up probably he was a
bit stronger at the time of this game
but uh what what would you say if i were
to tell you
that michael john baseman was not just
doing this to you know these random
you know fairly high level uh chess
players throughout
england he was doing it to england's
best chess players and we'll see
with the final game of the lecture he
did something even more absurd
against the one and only olf anderson uh
of course
incredible chess player uh and he's
getting away with it in all these games
so why don't we take a look now at one
jonathan spielman
let's see how spielman took on michael
john baseman
and what funny opening moves we have in
store this time
so one e4 was played
and perhaps michael john baseman in
light of the game with frank babar
realized that h6 is just not good enough
right h6 isn't good enough it gives them
time
to get on this diagonal stopping his
idea of g5
right so he makes an improvement he
plays g5 first
good luck playing b3 now buddy i'm
getting on the diagonal
right so one g5 by michael john basement
of course this opening
sometimes known as the borg not named
after the star trek characters
but named after the grub opening in
reverse
g-r-o-b and backwards of course is
b-o-r-g
the borg and that's what we have here
from basement
uh now jonathan takes a little bit more
of a classical approach to trying to
refute this stuff
not going for these double fianchettos
sort of wasting time
back but instead seizing the center
directly challenging the pawn on g5
we see now h6 by michael john baseman
you know he's crazy but he's not that
crazy his pawn's attacked he's going to
defend it
and then chat how would you like to go
about
um challenging uh black's position here
h6 g5 is on the board you've spent your
two moves playing e4 d4
probably you should have some advantage
here but how do you prove it what do you
want to do
what do you want to do and yeah i think
this is going
to be the opportunity to talk about some
common mistakes
that are made when people end up in
these kinds of positions
so what jonathan spielman decided to do
and what is a perfectly acceptable way
of playing
is play the move h4 he wanted to break
things open on the h file directly
force concessions from michael john
basement directly
before he could even get developed so
in this case h4 is actually going to be
a very very good move
why is that well there's no good way for
black to defend
this pawn uh of course this is pinned
along the h file indirectly if bishop g7
is played we see h takes g
and h takes g and at the end of the day
this bishop comes in to save the day and
win a pawn for
white of course e6 doesn't do it because
then this pin
is very very relevant so
black is faced with this awkward
decision he has to go g4 or he has to
take on h4
in this game we see g takes h4 by
michael baseman
but backing up here let's talk about
some of the things i was seeing
in the chat i saw a lot of people
actually
suggesting the move e5 and i think this
is a horrible horrible
mistake why is e5 a horrible horrible
mistake
well as always even when your opponent
is sort of wasting time
in the opening there's a very very fine
line
between having central space and being
over
extended uh of course notably in
openings like the french and cairo khan
if you moved these pawns over here these
pawns over here i guess
then you would get the exact same
structure and black isn't all together
unhappy about it this uh is a good way
to end up with weak pawns in the center
but i could immediately start
challenging these
pawns with something like d6 if uh
white ends up taking c takes d5
next thing you know yes black played h6
g5 and spent time doing it
but white played e4 e5 e takes d
right so not exactly the you know
fastest opening play getting developed
by white either
neither side would have any pieces
developed and black is actually sort of
well prepared to open up this diagonal
bearing down on the queen side so e5
would be a very very bad mistake i think
my personal way my personal favorite way
to play against these kinds of openings
is not really to do the crazy stuff like
h4 yes in this particular case it gives
you
very definite advantages which is
probably why spielman decided to play it
but my favorite thing to do is develop
my pieces right
you know i say to my opponent do
whatever you want i'm developing my
pieces
something like queen d2 uh knight c6
queenside castles and you just develop
your pieces
right if you just develop your pieces in
this case
you are always going to get a good
position here
no matter what your opponent is sort of
doing as long as you're developing your
pieces and you're careful about it you
know
acknowledging any threats they're making
in the center then
you're just going gonna get a good
position let me flip on the engine here
this position is plus two right all
white did is develop his pieces
and the engine gives plus two here why
does it give plus two
well it's because black is without a
plan and white's pawns are not over
extended
for example black would love to play
something like e5
but this doesn't even force a response
now by whites doesn't even force white
to overextend the simple move
f3 and white is defending all of his
weaknesses
uh you know very very well
but that's not we see in this game in
this game uh jonathan
out for blood plays the move h4 and
as i did say we do see g takes h4 by
michael john baseman
rook takes h4 activating the rook may as
well
d5 now for uh basement
challenging the center a couple moves
late but you know
still adamant about controlling the
center eventually
e takes d5 is spielman's response and
now if queen takes d5 i think the
issue is just that knight c3 is coming
with tempo
and you know the queen d8 scandinavian
might be playable
when you go d5 queen d5 queen d8
immediately but here
it's just not going to work you're
wasting too much time so
this turns into uh
the move e6 the point being black is
taking advantage of the
temporarily awkward placement of this
rook in order to capture back on d5 with
the pawn
rook h5 is played knight f6
gains time on the rook again or does it
we see d takes e6 and now knight takes
h5
might not be the most advisable when
your king is getting pushed
uh way out into the open and white is
getting plenty of pawns
so after d takes e we saw bishop takes
e6 and it is just upon sacrifice
and then spielman gives up this rook on
h5
which probably is unnecessary
and i think now
knight takes h5 queen takes h5 yes white
still has a very decent position
but i think i think black is sort of out
of the worst of it here
and this is a pretty significant mistake
i think both objectively
and you know sort of practically
psychologically
practically over the board i think this
is a pretty huge mistake
why is that well if uh jonathan
had instead chosen just to sort of
retreat this rook all the way back to h1
even
and we see some move like knight b to d7
or maybe even like
c5 uh what do we have here well we have
white
with an extra pawn you know three pawns
missing for black
only two pawns missing for white and we
have white
with less weaknesses in the position
spawn on d4 is sort of the only thing
that's been advanced
that you know could be considered a
weakness whereas this pawn on h6 is
going to be very very weak
this pawn on f7 is isolated and all
white has to do now is develop simply
and he's going to have a very nice
advantage
right white's going to have an advantage
here up an extra pawn
black has some development in exchange
for it but black like i said
all the long term things are in white's
favor
now what do we see after knight c3 takes
and takes
well rather than being down upon
for nothing black is up the exchange
for a pawn and this gives black
something to play for right
you know the pressure is no longer on
black black doesn't have to you know
fight back to win material
make use of this development right away
black now can sort of sit back
and say yeah i'm up material you know
my h6 g5 stuff is is really uh working
out for me here i'm up the exchange on
move nine
why doesn't everybody play like this and
that's a good question
so bishop b4 was played in the game just
natural development now for michael
basement knight e2
knight c6 of course there's no d5
thanks to the pin on the king and now
bishop e3
for white and queen d7 for black
and i want to mention something else
about uh
basement's play in this opening here of
course he goes crazy on the king side h6
g5 things get opened up
but notably you see both players
actually leave this nice little pawn
shield
on the queen side and that's generally
the thing you have to do
when you're playing these types of crazy
openings with either side
right you have to have some kind of plan
for your king
in the first game his game stayed in the
center
but also in that game the center was
very very closed
and it only opened up when white was
sacrificing pieces on f7
which may have not been the most
advisable
so here center is open so both players
leave the queen side open for their
kings
a3 is now white's decision and i think
this move is
perfectly fine trying to force this
bishop to
make a decision if it wants to trade
itself off here and bring white's other
knight into the game
or retreat michael throws in a very nice
inner meso here in the form of bishop g4
the queen goes to b5
and now who is it really that was
breaking opening principles this whole
time this queen is getting
kicked around black is using the extra
time to develop his pieces even more
queen d3 is played we now do see bishop
take c3
and not knight takes c3 when castling
would be made temporarily illegal but
queen takes c3 instead
and queen side castles for black
f3 for white bishop e6
and queen side castles for white
and now we are nearing the end of the
opening
and what has happened well at the end of
the day
black has all these same weaknesses that
we talked about earlier but both sides
have gotten castled
black's pieces are fully developed white
is almost fully developed you could
argue that this bishop needs some work
but i think it's
it's going to be reasonably fine has
plenty of squares to choose from on the
uh on this diagonal and it's not that
bad on f1 either
keeping an eye on the a6 pawn but
black's up in exchange
why is black up in exchange well because
jonathan spielman
wanted to be a hero wanted to sacrifice
early on to try and refute the
opponent's opening
in my opinion that is a recipe for
disaster
the way to play against these openings
is not in this form of jonathan spielman
in my opinion
uh it while the objective best moves
will lead you to victory in most cases
against these things
it's hard to play objectively correct
chess against this style of play
why is that you have no intuition right
these these positions are just
absolutely crazy you have to calculate
on every turn and try to get your pieces
to squares that make
some kind of sense and if you can't do
that then if you play this ultra
combative style with
h4 and rook takes h4 you might find
yourself on the worst and
the worst end of things with the white
pieces and that's exactly what happened
to jonathan spielman
now if you do what i suggested develop
your pieces
control the center i think it is much
much easier to play
don't try to refute the opening just
find squares for your pieces and then
you can play a chess game
okay though the game continues white is
making a threat look out
knight e7 is michael's choice gaining
control again of the d5 square
knight f4 for white now again making
this threat so knight d5 blockades we
see
takes takes the queen actually comes
back to d2 now
and queen c6 and white has the bishop
pair
black still has these weaknesses but why
is white down in exchange
i don't know i don't understand this
sacrifice
from jonathan spielman but that's what
happened in the game
so king b1 and now black goes about the
business of fixing the problems in his
position
so that his extra rook can be felt this
pawn is very very weak
so in classic uh basement style he says
yeah i'll push it forward
bishop g5 attacks a rook or d to e8
saves a rook something jonathan spielman
should take some notes on perhaps
bishop f4 bishop c4
black now uh offers the trade of the
light squared bishops to get rid of this
bishop pair
and i think at this at this point uh
it's pretty clear
that black is the one with all the
advantage in
this case this h pawn is no longer
really weak the bishop pair is coming
off the board and black is just in
exchange
for a pawn ahead bishop e5 was played
this rook has to move but
not it's not so unhappy about it
pressuring the g pawn
d5 by spielman was the choice but this
just tactically fails to bishop takes d5
and now of course queen takes d5 would
be met
with i believe queen takes d5 right
am i seeing this correctly yeah queen
takes d5
this was simpler okay yeah queen takes
d5 and f6 right for some reason i was
thinking c6 but of course
um no wait not f6 oh god there's like
one tactic in this whole game and i'm
messing it up
interesting i'll have to have to cheat
here momentarily
oh god it's all going downhill it's all
going downhill
all right where are we there's one
tactic in the whole game and i can't
even figure it out
all right of course queen takes d5 would
fail to rook d8
with this okay yes skewer everybody know
skewers i thought it was this bishop on
e5 but no there is rook d8 so d5
unfortunately just
a losing move due to the tactic found by
michael baseman
not found by me better chess player than
i uh and so queen d4 was played instead
but this is the beginning of the end now
uh bishop to b3
was the try for uh
for michael baseman and this actually
doesn't work this uh this
actually does lose the game back uh rook
d8 was the simple move
and it was the correct move bishop a2
check is sort of impossible to stop
along with the threat of just any bishop
move challenging these guys for example
king c1 would mean bishop f3 and
this is busto but bishop b3 actually
doesn't quite work
white could capture this guy and white
actually does have a counter tactic
after rook d8
with the move rook c1 and so
jonathan spielman could have actually
still won this game because the tactics
got a bit messy here but instead bishop
d3 was played and now rook d8
and black once again is firmly in
control takes on d3
queen b6 there's no checkmate and
exchange up now pawns up
this was a clean victory from here on
out
for michael john baseman pushing on the
king's side
and here white ended up resigning so
not just patzers that michael john
baseman is beating with this
h6 and g5 stuff he has taken down
jonathan spielman what was spielman's
mistake in this game
well of course the tactics were messy
there were chances for wolf players
eventually
but at its core i think uh jonathan
spielman's mistake
was trying to refute the opening with
this h4 rook
h4 rook h5 stuff you just don't need to
do this this is what players with the
black pieces want you to do
because they they thrive on the
craziness they thrive on it
they are playing these positions on
purpose and you don't need to get sucked
into that stuff
you can in fact just develop your pieces
just develop your pieces just knight c3
fish p3 stuff like fs
f3 you know you don't even need to
engage
don't even need to engage here just
queen side castles
knight c6 and black's position is
just going to crumble eventually in fact
i think this is
already immediately just very very good
for white winning winning material
already if black were to play like this
so that's my advice
if you face this just develop your
pieces alright
so that's one great english chess player
down who's up next
who's up next well how about famed
author
and chess composer john nunn that's
right
even john nunn was falling victim to
michael john baseman's uh craziness here
and let's just jump into the game why
waste any time
so the previous two games we've seen
michael baseman with the black pieces
doing this sort of absurdity with g5 and
h6
now we'll give him a shot with the white
pieces and again we are going to see
the g-pawn move with one g4
d5 by john nunn hits this pawn on g4
and now we see h3 by white defending the
pawn
e5 is the follow-up now for john nunn
and we see
d3 for michael john baseman so i think
what he is attempting to do here is
go for some kind of light squared
control right this is sort of the
the idea at the heart of the grub you
put this bishop on g2
and you start trying to break down all
of these light squares
for black and at the end of the day
you get some kind of awful english where
these two pawns should be here and you
should have two extra moves
but you know since you want to play the
grub you put the pawns here instead
and waste two moves doing it but at its
core you know it has a good idea
it's a similar idea to the english so
let's see if
uh white is able to enact this here we
do see c4
land on the board c6 knight c3
white using all of his moves now to
challenge these central light squares
after going you know of course g4 h3
first
knight e7 knight f3 h5 now for
black and again we see g takes h5 and
rook takes h5
and everybody loves doing this ever like
everybody seems to think
this is the way to play against the grab
and while it does make some sense right
you want to target this weak h
pawn why not force this concession from
white
at the same time i think black's time
just would have been better served
developing right you can castle king's
side here
right develop the bishop to e6 you know
develop the knight to d7 even go f5
later go f6 if you want to be solid just
preserve your center don't get sucked in
to the nonsense
but instead we do see h5 and rook h5
bishop e2 bishop d2 is the idea now
for whites and after a6 i want to
ask you guys to find michael john
baseman's
next move i think this one is actually a
pretty instructive one here
because you know it might be
counter-intuitive at first glance
to find the move that michael does end
up playing but i think
it is quite sensible in many of these
positions that you actually end up in
with the grub
what is this opening called yeah
technically it is called
the grab the grab attack some might say
is it safe to castle into g4 your
position is always safe when you have
pieces developed and your opponent does
not
when you control the center pieces are
developed your position is safe
also in that position i showed
of course black's knight being on e7
rather than f6 is actually
pretty advantageous because it means g5
is not going to come with tempo
and black would have plenty of time to
do something about it so
c takes d4 is not actually the idea
um knight a4 is definitely not the idea
why
you don't want to move pieces away from
the center and yeah
e4 is going to be the very good idea for
white in this position
that i wanted to talk about so why e4 it
seems to run
you know sort of against our entire plan
of putting the bishop on g2
and breaking down the light squares well
if you take a look
at black's moves knight e7 uh b7
c6 uh d5
bishop e6 i'm sure is to follow along
with the opening up
of half of the g file here you can
easily imagine a major piece landing on
the g file pressuring this bishop
well white is playing very or black is
playing very much against this idea
of playing bishop g2 and this move e4
is actually forcing black to make very
concrete decisions
right away right now black skin is in
the center
white's king is in the center and
neither of them really know what they're
going to do
and so if black plays the move d4
white is going to be very happy to bring
to actually play a tactic here with
knight takes d4 but even if the tactic
didn't exist
now knight a4 would be very playable
with the idea of c5 and knight b6 to
follow
or even something like 90 to knight g6
knight g3
i think would be fine for white
right just in general here the closing
of the center i think is going to be in
white's favor
because white's king was sort of sitting
so forlorn
in the center of the board like this
so i don't think black's happy about
closing the center in general
in these positions and specifically
there is a tactic here
where queen takes h5 dc3 and bishop c3 i
think
would materially go in white's favor
with the king side sort of crumbling as
well
so black now has to decide what he wants
to do
with this d-pawn if he tries to just
keep it on the board with something
like uh bishop to e6 you might see
these come off the board and now knight
g5 and now the
light squares are finally actually
crumbling along this diagonal
if he plays the move d takes e4 well
that's what happened in the game
and white was happy to take back with
the pawn
notably do you take c4 would have
achieved the same and was maybe better
for black since
you don't allow any possibility of
knight takes e4
and then you end up in this position and
what's going on in this position
well white is sort of shifting the story
away
from the king's side weaknesses now the
d file has opened up as well
and i think this is where a lot of the
conflict might happen
for control of you know this the center
black is going to have to be very very
wary now
of how he develops the pieces with this
bishop sitting on d6 a little bit loose
and the queen still stuck on d8 so
knight d7
was played by black and now how should
white continue
right you've got some problems to solve
here the king is stuck in the center
this queen doesn't really belong in the
open file you'd rather have a rook there
speaking of there's a rook still on a1
how do you activate the pieces
how do you activate the pieces here with
white
because this is always your goal in the
opening even when you're playing the
crazy stuff
your goal is to find activity
so queen e2 or c2 seems normal
yes it would seem normal and these are
playable moves
for white but much better is actually
the move knight
g5 you take advantage once again of this
misplaced rook it's becoming sort of a
theme
in these games you know black seemingly
very happy about g takes h5 rick takes
h5
but then always wasting a ton of tempe
moving this rook around
or in jonathan spielman's case just
losing the rook entirely
so knight g5 did appear on the board
knight f6 was black's best try to not
lose time with the rook
and now queen f3 is actually a much
better square than either e2 or
c2 when now it is again white with all
of the pressure
in the position right this little h pawn
in h3 that looked so weak moments ago
is defended no fewer than four times and
it's seemingly totally irrelevant to the
position right how is black
going to fix his king how is black going
to fix these pieces
uh and what what does black have in
exchange for all this well a half open
age file
with some pressure on the h3 pawn just
doesn't seem like enough to me
knight g6 was the follow-up for black
and now of course queen side castles
and once again despite playing a wild
and crazy opening
michael john baseman has found um you
know harmony
for all of his pieces right this knight
on g5 very actively placed pressuring
f7 in tandem with the queen this knight
on c3 might not have
very good jumping prospects yet but you
know it has a future can always reroute
to the king's side
this bishop can land on e3 pressuring
both sides of the board
supporting the knight the rook's on an
open file
this rook can come to g1 at a moment's
notice and
yeah white's pieces all looking very
sensible black's
black stroke on h5 is a bit loose
although active against the h pawn
this bishop is not looking ideal either
and the king
queen and rook are all still stuck
on the starting squares this bishop as
well going to struggle to find a place
to develop out to
with all of these squares under white's
control
so the moral of the story is in these
openings
it doesn't matter what you're playing it
doesn't matter what you're playing
the downside to g4 is that if black
plays very very accurately
uh then he can maybe get some advantage
with this h5
style of stuff but the real downside in
my opinion
is black's opportunity to just develop
his pieces without a fight
that is the real reason why these
openings are bad
practically in my opinion black
could just develop normally just put all
the pieces on squares and then have a
perfectly fine position
but in these games where white ends up
winning it's usually because black is
you know trying really hard to prove
that this opening is just
strictly unplayable uh and that's just
not the way to do things
so white again the victor in this
opening battle
we see queen e7 king b1
just putting the king on a safer square
knight f4 now
for black rook g1 bringing the rook into
the game and supporting this knight
king f8 is how black decides to solve
the problem of his king
but still this is not an ideal placement
for this guy
knight e2 and white again is now
rerouting his final pieces
over to the attack this knight comes
back to e6
we see a trade on e6 the second knight
coming into g3 now
and bishop g5 and again
all of white's pieces serving a useful
purpose here
even this bishop defending this pawn in
the meantime
the rooks for black uncoordinated
these pieces looking at nothing on the
king's side this bishop is useless
and yeah i will say this bishop does
look pretty nice on e6
this rook does exert some pressure on
the h file
but in my opinion just total harmony for
white versus a very very disjointed
position here for black and that is why
white has the advantage
rook d8 bishop e2 is played in the game
and look at that
john nunn got to take his age pawn he
did it
opening refuted unplayable h pawn falls
um but of course just queen g2 now
and black is wasting even more time with
this rook it seems bishop c7
was john nunn's choice in the game but
this move does turn out to be
a pretty fatal mistake knight h5 appears
on the board
and now there's no real way to stop
the mounting threats against the black
king rook takes d1 was played bishop
takes d1
sorry rook takes d1 instead um now again
these threats are a bit too strong i
think bishop takes and queen g7 queen g8
would be
mate uh to the king
with the rook on the d file and so john
nunn felt it was time
to lose this rook again on the h file
again
becoming a bit of a theme here bishop
takes h5 white is up the exchange
and the game liquidated shortly after
queen b4
bishop b2 is played takes on c4 c
captures captures captures captures
queen g4 queen e6 captures captures rook
d7
and jon nunn threw in the towel another
victim
of michael baseman's opening nonsense
so manny in the chat says it doesn't
matter what you're playing if the
opponent doesn't punish it or plays
mistakes
well i think you're missing the point
manny the reason why these openings are
bad
practically why you don't see them more
often is because black again
does have the option to sort of ignore
the silliness
control the center don't overextend and
develop all the pieces
that is why i don't like these openings
not because of this crazy h4h5 stuff
trying to refute the opening that more
often than not
i think favors the side with the you
know quote objectively worse position
because they're just going to be more
familiar in it right it's a wild and
crazy position that's what they thrive
on that's why they're playing these
openings
so you don't have to give that to them
just develop your pieces
and life is good
all right it's the moment we've all been
waiting for i've been leading up to this
game the whole lecture
maybe i've done a bad job of building
suspense but this is the main event here
we are going to look at olf anderson
against michael john
baseman and now up to this point it's
been about what you would expect
from this lecture entitled horrible
openings you know your h6s your g5s your
g4s from michael john baseman
they're traditionally considered the
worst opening moves
and this game might not be what you're
what what you'd expect um
michael john baseman starts off you know
quite normally
you know uh according to normal
principles getting developed
but i think by the end of it you'll
agree with me this
is the worst opening michael john
baseman has played
all night and against i think the best
player as well maybe
you know john none and jonathan spielman
of course very excellent players i i
don't know how they match up against off
anderson actually specifically
but in my mind off anderson is just like
a legend so
we'll see what happens in this game
knight f3
by olf anderson and what do you think
john michael or michael john baseman
does
knight f3 refuting 1g5 by defending that
square how
dare olf do this does he go a6 does he
go
h6 these are also things that he's done
by the way a6h6
and then like you know e6 this is a
well-known opening of his as well
no he goes b6 an opening
that actually develops pieces right away
i was
i was shocked i was astounded so g3
appears on the board
bishop b7 getting developed okay so far
so normal
bishop g2 he even goes e6 he's
developing a second bishop
what is this this is not the michael
john baseman i know
castles he goes d5 moving
upon into the center of the board to
control space
wow shocking revolutionary ideas
uh c4 for white both players playing
very sensible moves knight f6 now for
black
a move that develops the knight controls
the center and doesn't horribly weaken
the king's side
so far so good d4 bishop e7
we just have a very normal catalan style
position
knight c3 castles 95
and here michael john baseman does play
h6 which okay you know i mean
he's michael john you got it he's gonna
play h6 at some point okay why not here
it's not the worst move ever
um bishop f4 and now
this is usually the phase of the game
right we're still solidly in the opening
i would say
this is where the plans usually start to
take shape for both sides right
normally straight out of the opening
you're going to see both sides starting
to develop
some kind of plan you know they're going
to decide am i activating my pieces on
you know the king side am i playing for
a pawn break
over here am i challenging the center
with some move like c5
and this is normally the part of the
game where that would start to become
very very clear right both players
played normal developing moves
got the bishops out got castled and now
it's sort of decision time
for both sides what do both players want
to play for
so what do you think michael john
baseman decided
he wanted to play for in this position
what should he do here
you know you're playing with black
against this cat
[Music]
[Music]
should i start over from a few moves ago
yes all right
all right welcome back a few technical
issues there hopefully now
the uh stream issue is fixed so let's
look back at this position
right so where hopefully you last heard
me i was talking up a big game about
this position talking about what black
should be trying to do in this position
what a normal chess player would do and
i mentioned this idea
knight a6 or you know something like
knight d7 either move makes a lot of
sense
just getting the knight developed and
then after a few more normal moves
we would probably see something like c5
by black you know breaking in the center
as you're taught to do
following up on your opening entering
the middle game
phase by achieving you know some sort of
position with about level chances for
either side
it's every chess player's dream with the
black pieces right you just get a chess
game
you know something like c takes d5 and d
takes c5 is perfectly playable
and i was talking about maybe getting
some kind of iqp
right some normal chest position right
everybody's played in iqp at some point
in their lives
black has good control over e4 can
activate the pieces on the cne files
and life would be good life would be
normal but no
not michael john baseman instead of
finishing development here and playing
something like c5 which
you know is perfectly perfectly
reasonable for black
although admittedly this move h6 does
seem a little bit like wasted tempo to
me
you place the move a6 first right and i
i didn't really understand this move at
first i don't know what he's
hoping to accomplish here white plays
the perfectly natural rook c1
and then black plays rook a7 and i
definitely didn't see this coming
so what is black's idea well perhaps if
white plays another slow move
then black was interested in playing d
take c4
with the point being that he has
defended his bishop one way or another
however of course there's an obvious
refutation to this idea
which is the fact that white can capture
on d5
now after capture on d5 black really
isn't interested in taking back with
knight because at the end of the day the
door is going to get shut on this bishop
with something like e4
and white is now going to have a very
very substantial advantage
moves like queen a4 coming even moves
like knight g4
are perfectly playable as well with the
ideas of d5 to follow up
pressure on the c file white's going to
be killing it here
so after c takes d5 black played the
move e takes d5
and closed up the center now white plays
the move queen b3 so like
you know so far a6 rook a7 yeah it's a
cute idea
it's a little bit unique it's probably
not objectively the greatest
but that probably isn't deserving of
getting into
a lecture on the worst openings of all
time
right so why did i include this well
it's because of what happens next right
you can argue
that we're out of the opening but in my
opinion a critical part of the opening
is forming a solid plan for what comes
next either responding to your
opponent's plan
or you know doing something yourself for
counter play
playing for c5 you know playing for
pressure on the e
pawn or something playing to just even
trade pieces is
you know a plan of some sort it's
usually not a great plan but it's a plan
right
so what do you think michael john
baseman went for
in this case in this position what plan
did he
did he choose
what plan does michael john basement go
for well of course
as everybody knows from the movie war
games
sometimes the only way to win is to not
play at
all and so michael john baseman chooses
uh what is probably the worst plan in
many many cases but
seemingly working for him here he
chooses no plan at all
what does that look like well he starts
with the move bishop a8
which is arguably improving the bishop
right i was a bit vulnerable
on b7 some tactics sometimes on the
diagonal or the file
not that diagonal but this diagonal and
on aid it's
a little bit tucked away rook fd1 and
then
king h7 appears on the board
and then after h3 you know just a simple
improving move by white
king g8 appears on the board king h2
proving move by white and then king age
seven appears on the board
and then g4 is is played you know white
now taking space on the king's side sort
of catching on to what's
what's happening here and then king g8
is played and then bishop e3 another
perfectly fine improving move by white
and then bishop back to b7 you know why
not the a8 was getting you know
boring may as well come back to b7 and
then e3 is played by white you know
controlling this central pawn
and then bishop a8 is is michael john
baseman's response and then a3 by white
taking even more more squares away from
black and then bishop b7 again
and now you know olf you know olf buddy
he's known for his crushing end game
technique
he himself plays some sort of odd
openings with black he's a big hedgehog
type guy
in many cases these sort of openings
where you don't directly go for the
center
sort of appeal to him in many cases but
you know even he has his limits right so
after let's see what is this this is the
past
eight moves black has just shuffled back
and forth doing
absolutely nothing maybe you know olfi
here is getting a little bit bored
plays the move f4 and he's like all
right all right f4 what are you going to
do
about that one buddy i'm coming after
you
and so of course michael john baseman
plays the move bishop a8
and then uh here of course
of course of course white is winning you
cannot do this with black
and achieve an objectively good position
you can't give your opponent
9 10 free tempe and then expect to come
out on the other side
with an objectively good position that
being said though
what do you do with the white pieces
like what do you do
what is like you don't what do you do
here right
so let's let's try and come up with some
sort of plan here
for white and see if
we can sort of refute michael john
baseman's idea here
of sitting and doing nothing
so you guys are on the right track here
of course
what white should do is take advantage
of the fact
that black's forces are sort of split
and very very
you know compact condensed uh by
white's extra space in the center and on
the king's side
and the way to take advantage of that
space in this case i think is to play
the move g5
and start opening things up along the
king's side
now of course you can play some more
preparatory moves which is what olf
anderson does especially especially
practically in this game
even if objectively the best move is to
play g5 immediately
if you're olf anderson and you're
sitting across the board from this guy
like why are you not going to bring all
the pieces to the king's side before you
do that
i i don't know it's pretty clear to me
that he's not interested in improving
his position so
rook d2 was off's choice first but yeah
i think you guys are on the right track
moves like g5 are really what ulf should
be doing
queen d6 now for black f5 queen back to
d8
you know apologies to olf says michael
john baseman that almost looked like an
active try better come back to d8 here
you opened up the diagonal and you
showed me
bishop f4 bishop back to b7 it's
becoming a familiar picture
rook over to g1 now olf is uh sort of
you know getting into high gear and now
c6 is our first
new move that changes the position by
michael john baseman
unfortunately uh it is just a move that
you know
sort of further relegates him to
passivity bishop f3 appears on the board
now
unleashing this idea and now knight age
seven
while still sort of doing nothing
michael is at least at this point
responding to his opponent's threats
rook c1 now switches sides a bit we see
bishop d6
and after knight a4 bishop c7 black has
sort of restructured his pieces slightly
uh king g3 knight back to f6 h4
now knight back to d7 and here believe
it or not
white has sort of um lost most of his
advantage
already which is hard to believe right
but it turns out
that olf with moving these rooks back
and forth sort of delaying
what he wanted to do has allowed black
to favorably restructure his position
now it's true that all of black's pieces
are sort of jumbled together
on the king's side and they're all sort
of serving very passive roles
they are are sort of just counteracting
all of the white minor pieces
and white's ideas on the king's side are
now going to come with a little bit
less force because black is going to get
some counter play on this dark squared
diagonal
of course of course of course white is
still better
but you know it's it's not all uh it's
not all lost
for black so what should white have done
well it turns out
way back here after something like queen
d6 this move f5
turned out to be a pretty critical
mistake so
let's talk about why f5 turned out to be
such a crucial mistake in this game
well of course uh white's idea to play
against
you know black setup here should be to
open up
files uh either in the center of the
board or on the king's side
and this pawn being on f4 is a really
critical uh contributor to that right
it supports this knight on e5 so it can
sort of never be moved
supports ideas of g5 and indirectly by
supporting the knight on e5
it's actually helping to facilitate the
idea of e4 right you never have to worry
about issues on the file
uh because this knight is so so solid
here on e5 so with
f5 white is actually giving up a lot of
his
grip on the position and the second we
see f5 be played
uh the seemingly random shuffling from
michael john baseman
actually turns into very purposeful
shuffling right you see him regroup
all of his pieces uh to yes defend the
b6 pawn but
also counter attack on the e5 square
so i'm going to say that f5 is the
reason why olf anderson
isn't just winning this game outright so
that's important to keep in mind you
know even if your opponent
is you know staring at you with impunity
and just shuffling back and forth
forever
that doesn't mean you can just push all
the way up the board
every pawn move definitely comes with
weaknesses
and drawbacks and the reason john
baseman or michael john basement is
still in the game
is because of this weakness slight
slight weakness on e5
and here ulf actually cracks under the
pressure he should have just stuck with
this knight on e5 done something like
queen c3 to even further
reinforce it then continued with
something like b4
as well getting as much space as
possible on the queen side
instead he takes on d7 and this move of
course improves black's uh
saddest piece on b8 and after this
black isn't worse it's a quality here
suddenly suddenly black is is very much
still in the game
we see rookie 2 now e4 is still olf's
idea but it's sort of too little too
late
rookie 8 black is ready to meet it king
h3 appears on the board
we see a trade of pieces on f4 traded
pieces on e2
now queen e7 by michael john baseman
bishop f3 b5
knight c5 bishop back to uh c8
it does turn out that this move is
actually a bit better because
uh you know that knight was very very
powerful and getting rid of it as soon
as possible makes a lot of sense but
bishop c
is fine queen d3 and now uh black to
move
and start playing for the advantage what
do you guys think
black to move and start playing for the
advantage
what do you guys think well it turns out
here
that as always when pushing forward
taking space it comes with drawbacks the
drawbacks are the weaknesses left behind
this pawn on f5 for the moment seems
very very solid
but after the move h5 white needs to be
cautious
in this case olf anderson makes one
fatal mistake here
it actually captures on h5 perhaps he
was still dreaming of some kind of
attack you know i'll play h6 rook g1
but it's just too little too late now
and these
sort of you know this is the worst pawn
structure i've seen in a long time here
h4 h5 f4 f5 it's just bad
uh and now black is better queen f6 was
played in the game
knight takes c5 and that's an extra pawn
for michael john baseman and ulf
collapsed fairly shortly after chumbay's
been getting
to the e file now and pushing c5
finally um queen takes c5 does turn out
to be the final mistake of the game
this queen is distracted from its
defensive role on
the uh king side does turn out that d
takes c5 would have been a playable move
for white although d4 is going to be
putting some pressure on white's
position here
rookie 3 bishop c6 to follow but queen
c5 played in the game and now queen f5
is absolutely totally winning for black
queen h3
is pretty impossible to stop here
queen takes d5 was played in the game
now queen h3 check king f2
queen h2 check bishop g2 three pawns
for michael john baseman bishop f3
bishop g4 now
increasing the pressure here also by the
way this rook has attacked
rook c3 queen back to h2 check bishop g2
more free pawns king g1 rookie one check
bishop f1 bishop f bishop h3
and resignation so uh
as i said i think this is the worst
opening of the night by michael john
basement not because
of the opening itself you know the first
starting moves of course were very very
reasonable it was just a normal queens
indian type of structure
putting the bishop on b7 but after that
a critical critical part of the opening
is the plan that you develop along the
way how you want to
engage in the early middle game and
michael john baseman
stopped playing that he said no i'm done
i developed
half of my pieces that's good enough my
king's castle what do i care
and he passed back and forth over and
over and over
and over again and then crushed uh
a fantastic chess player olf anderson
and that is the lecture tonight
hopefully you guys
enjoyed these pretty incredible games by
uh basement
i had a lot of fun looking at them
beforehand and talking to you guys about
them
is there anything to take away from
these games if there is
one really really critical instructive
point that i want you guys to remember
it's this idea of not trying to refute
bad openings right when your opponent
plays a bad opening you
do not need to refute it straight away
uh you need to take your time develop
your pieces
and play a normal game of chess you know
even if you look at it afterwards with
the computer and the computer says oh
you're an idiot play h4 this is so good
for you
uh i would recommend just playing good
solid normal chess and then you really
can't go wrong
against the the craziness even if you're
playing a legend like michael
john baseman uh that's it for me here
tonight uh
i will be continuing live on twitch
directly after this with tactics time
once again thank you all so much for
watching my name is caleb denby and i
will see you
next time
[Music]
you